[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETER DER MANUELIAN: We have all of this archeological evidence
and documentation for Giza from the great excavations
in the early part of the 1900s.
So why move into visualization and 3D?
Can that help us with our scholarship?
Is there something new to learn here?
Well, take a look at some of these examples with me.
'Where's the best place to study Giza?' is an interesting question to ask.
Of course, out at the site is a wonderful place,
and I'm never going to advocate that no one ever
go there or use some kind of substitute for visiting the site of Giza itself.
It is a spectacular experience.
However, in many ways, you can study Giza better
from archival documentation.
And I will argue even from 3D visualization.
So take a look at this photograph from about 1927.
And if you look at the condition of this scene today,
unfortunately, it's in much sadder shape.
The figures are deteriorated.
It's hard to recognize what's going on.
So there's a case where we turn to the archives.
Or how about this.
We're now in the Berlin museum, and you're
seeing the facade of the tomb of Merib.
If you went back to Giza, you would see a hole in the ground
because this chapel was removed in the 1840s.
So through 3D visualization, such as you see in this model,
we can virtually repatriate the Chapel of Merib back to Giza
and experience it right where it originally belonged.
Another example of then and now you see a man carrying an oryx or a gazelle
on the left in pretty good condition.
And on the right, unfortunately, suffering terribly.
So our approach is to try to visualize the entire Giza Plateau.
That's not to eliminate all the great archeological evidence, the dig
photos, and diaries, and maps or a visit to study
the originals up close and personal.
All of these things are critical.
But by making a 3D model of the site, we can now
get to areas that normal humans don't have access to,
and we can start to ask some new research questions that
were previously impossible.
And the important point is this isn't a video game.
It's based on the sound archeological evidence of many, many decades
of hard work by our predecessors.
So that means starting with maps and plans and section drawings
and building up computer models in wireframes,
and then texture mapping them and adding different types of stone casing types
and other types of colors.
And eventually, we get a photo-realistic appearance of these buildings.
It also means that we can repatriate or build 3D models of specific objects
and put them right back into the rooms that they were originally found in.
So this enhances our understanding of the archeological context of the site.
Something we don't get, of course, if we visit Gaza today.
Many of these objects are now in museums.
And since we're paying close attention to the archeological record,
we could take something like the tomb Hetepheres, which
was found in 1925 with so much of the wood
and materials deteriorated that it was just a pile of debris on the floor.
But thanks to the careful documentation, that has allowed us to build a 3D model
and even restore all of the Queens furniture.
You'll learn more about that in another module.
I'm often fond of saying, I would love to see the "tomb's-eye view" of Giza.
In other words, to dive down into the underground limestone bedrock
and look upwards and see all of those wonderful burial
shafts leading up into the mastaba tombs.
Well, with 3D modeling, we can do that.
Mortals can dive into limestone.
But we can hover around and rotate around burial shafts
and get a real sense of how these substructures of these buildings
connect and relate to the superstructures below ground
and above ground.
And in this particular image, you see the original excavation photo
of a burial chamber in 1906.
And then the modeling, the wireframe, and then the completed reconstruction.
This is a room that is underground.
It's completely sanded over again.
And no one has been there since 1906.
And of course, 1906 was black and white photography.
So through our 3D modeling, we can recreate aspects of this chamber
faithfully reproduced based on the archeological evidence,
but now in color and now with complete freedom of movement.
Eventually, we'll be building all of the Giza Plateau,
and we hope to lend the kind of detail and meticulous care
to the structure of every single mastaba.
Its casing types, its shapes of limestone blocks,
its chapel decoration.
This is a big job, and it may involve crowdsourcing.
But one by one, we can actually model the entire site in faithful detail.
In terms of the royal temples, we too have things
to learn here from visualization.
On the floor of Khafre's Valley Temple here, you see the emplacements
or is rectangular niches or holes in the floor partially restored today,
but those originally contained the bases of statues of Khafre.
The question is, how big were they?
Were the platforms big?
Were the statues big?
So by placing our 3D models in these emplacements in the floor,
we can start to experiment, and get a sense of how big
or how small they should be reconstructed.
Here is a very colorful rendering of the Menkaure Valley Temple.
Remember this was built in stone by Menkaure,
but he probably died too soon, and so his successor and son Shepseskaf
tried to finish it in mud brick.
It went through multiple building phases, indicated
by the white and the pinkish colors here, and then was actually inhabited.
All of those dwellings in the courtyard came later
towards the end of the Old Kingdom.
So we can almost magically pick these elements apart
and look at the temple at various points in time.
Empty, full, complete, half complete, limestone, mud brick,
all with different color coding.
That's something you don't get when you visit Giza itself.
This temple is completely buried, you won't see a thing today.
There are also ways to experiment with what you see on the walls.
In this example, we can actually point to items in the tomb
carvings and paintings such as furniture belonging to this queen.
And if we click on an element, it pops off the wall as a 3D model,
which we can then rotate in space and get a better understanding of.
Imagine if you could walk into a tomb and click
on absolutely anything that's represented on the chapel walls,
and have it pop into 3D real life for you.
Here's an example of some famous tombs that
have nothing surviving above ground.
No superstructure, just the subterranean decorated chambers.
So here again, with 3D modeling, we can experiment
what should be over these tomb areas.
Was it a mastaba?
Was it an enclosure wall?
Was it something simpler?
So once again, experimenting with visualization
can help us understand the development of this part of the cemetery further.
Sometimes you have to draw a clear line between what you're restoring
and what you know about what's archeologically attested.
So in this case, we're looking from the air at that dark patch
on the east side of the Great Pyramid.
That is all that remains of the basalt flooring of Khufu's pyramid temple.
Down below is a 3D model.
In this case, rather hypothetical based on other mortuary temples
that are from the same period, and with the same basalt flooring.
But again we have to delineate carefully what we know
and what we don't know what we are theoretically restoring.
We can even put human characters back into the scene.
This lends a sense of proportion, helps us understand the use of various areas,
and buildings better.
So in this view, you're looking at the central field.
That's the area now choked with tombs behind the Sphinx,
but before it was a cemetery.
It was the Quarry zone for all of the core limestone blocks
that went into the Great Pyramid.
And here you see thousands and thousands of Egyptians
hard at work in the Quarry carving the individual blocks that would then
be towed on sledges up to the Great Pyramid, which is just barely rising
in the distance in this model.
Simulations can help us as well.
Here's the subterranean chapel of Queen Meresankh.
And the arrow points to a window leading into the chapel.
Once we go inside, we can see if we reconstruct the course of the sunlight,
that the sun pierces through that window right through the room
and illuminates the false door or the sacred offering place
in another chamber.
That's something we wouldn't have known without building the 3D modeling.
And in fact, we can now think about where other neighboring buildings
and would they have blocked the sun coming into that window?
If so, does that tell us which tombs were first and which tombs were second?
And in fact, help us chronologically reconstruct
this part of the cemetery all based on a few shafts of sunlight in a window.
And now here's a case study.
This is a chapel of a man named Nefer.
He built this exterior stone chapel.
And where all the men are standing was once a beautifully
decorated four walls of this room.
Now, this gets tricky, follow along with me.
This entrance niche or jam is in Boston.
On the other side of the entrance, this piece is now in Paris.
If we go inside and look at the South wall,
the upper part of the standing couple is in Boston.
The rest of their bodies are still at Giza in the tomb.
We can put them together, and you can see them now reunited.
Then over to the west wall, it gets even more confusing.
This little block with part of the name of Nefer's wife
is in Birmingham England.
Right next door are two connecting pieces in Copenhagen.
And they also join a fragment still on the chapel wall itself at Giza.
Next to that is the upper part of the false door.
This is in Rome.
Put it all together, and it makes quite a jigsaw puzzle.
We're never going to do this physically, so here we're
just doing it photographically.
But the next step, of course, is 3D modeling.
There's nothing on the south wall.
But around onto the east wall, we have more pieces.
In this case, another fragment in Copenhagen and that one
joins to a standing representation of Nofer and his spouse
still on the chapel wall.
So putting all these pieces together virtually
is really the only way to understand this tomb.
From there, we can start to colorize the scenes,
understand the graphic inscriptions better, and in fact,
the relationships of all the decoration on these walls.
We can even recreate a 3D model of Reisner's Harvard camp, the expedition
headquarters to the west of Khafre's pyramid.
Here you see a rendering of the courtyard,
which was always full of statues and ceramics and stone vessel fragments.
This was the central headquarter hub where the expedition based everything,
wrote their publications, held court, entertained visitors, showed colleagues
around.
And this was really an integral part of the entire story
of the excavation of the Giza necropolis.